موضوع جدلي عراقي منصه بلغ منذ اطلاقها من
قبل وزاره الداخليه في العراق والجدل
مستمر حولها في اوساط صانعي المحتوى لكن
هذا الجدل ازداد وتحول لقلق خاصه بعد
اصدار مجلس القضاء الاعلى احكاما بالسجن
بحق عدد من صانعي المحتوى الهابط كما تصفه
السلطه كما سيتم ايضا تنظيم هذا الملف
بالتنسيق مع الانتربون لتسليم مشاهير
السوشل ميديا الذين
ستصدرهم احكام قضائيه ضدهم ممن يعيشون في
الخارج
ومع الجدل حول لائحه قواعد البث والذوق
العام ومن يحدده واعتقال عدد من صانعي
المحتوى اصدرت وزاره الداخليه شريطه فيديو
ترويجي لحملتها توضح انها لاقت ترحيبا
بجهود تحصين المجتمع من مشاهير السوشيال
ميديا من اصحاب المحتوى او المحتوى الهابط
بحسب وصفها المزيد مع زينب المشاط
اراء متطرفه جدا
خلتني افكر هواي واقعد اصفن ليش الناس
واصله لهالدرجه من الحقد والكره على هؤلاء
والله
فدوه لقلبك فدوه لقلبك هاي كل شي بيها
حياتي بيها تقييد للحريات ام تحجيمهم
للمحتوى الهابط جدل عراقي يسار بعد
انطلاقه منصه بلغ التابعه لوزاره الداخليه
العراقيه مستهدفه صانعي ما يسيء للذوق
العام وفقا لاحكام الماده
430 من قانون العقوبات واعلنت هذه المنصه
عن ان هنالك سته مدانين حتى الان بتهمه
الاساءه للذوق العام بينما يخضع ثمانيه
اخرون للتحقيق
[موسيقى]
تهمه مجهوله المعايير هكذا وصفها اغلب
النشطاء على مواقع التواصل فلم تفسر
الجهات الامنيه ولا القضائيه ماذا يعني
المحتوى الهابط وفق القانون العراقي وهل
سيشمل القرار اصحاب المحتوى السياسي من
البرلمانيين مثلا على كل حال هذا القرار
وجها انتقادات كثيره من المواطنين كما
سنرى
اي شيء اشوفه بنظر ان هو محتوى هابط ممكن
ابلغ عليه ماكو معايير للمحتوى الهابط
يعني مثلا هذا هي المحتويات الهابطه او
الاشخاص اللي نشالوا اللي اعتقلوهم على
مود المحتوى الهابط زين هم بالبدايه
المجتمع مو كان متقبلهم لو المجتمع ما
تقبلهم ما اشتروا هاي الشهره وصارت لهم
طشه ومشاهداتهم عبره الملايين يعني خوفش
من تتحول هاي القضيه الى يعني تقييد لحريه
الناس بالتعبير عن النفس وتكون العقوبات
تتوافق مع حجم المشكله يعني مبدئيا نعرف
كل الحياه تحتاج تدري ما نشوف الاجراءات
اللي صدرت بحق الصناع المحتوى هي اجراءات
قد تكون او قد اسميها تعسفيه
الجدل مستمر بل ومتصاعد خاصه بعد ان اعلنت
الجهات المعنيه عن نوايا جاده بايقاف بعض
البرامج التلفزيونيه وان القضاء يطالب
باستدعاء بعض صناع المحتوى المتواجدين
خارج العراق مصنفينهم كادوات لبث خطاب
الكراهيه وتهديد الدوله العراقيه بما
يقدمونه من موضوعات زينب المشهد صباح
العربيه بغداد
على كل ينضم الينا من بغداد اللواء خالد
محنن متحدث باسمي وزاره الداخليه العراقيه
ومن اسطنبول رسل المالكي كاتب وصانع محتوى
عراقي اهلا بكما معنا فقط مع وضد ابدا معك
حضرتي وانا افهم اكثر عن منصه بلغ خصوصا
في ظل الاتهامات لها بانه ليس لديها
معايير واضحه وكذلك تستهدف تكميم الافواه
وتهديد الحريات كيف تردون على من يقول ذلك
هو الحقيقه مؤخرا برزت ظاهره وهي الاساءه
الى المجتمع والى تقاليد
المجتمع العراقي الراسخه من خلال نشر
ابتدالات وقضايا تسيء الى الاخلاق العامه
لذلك باعتبار اليوم القانون العراقي يمنع
مثل هكذا تجاوزات على الاخلاق العامه وفق
مواد مختلفه لذلك وزاره الداخليه
باعتبارها جهه انفاذ القانون وهي المكلفه
عن انفاذ القوانين
اطلقت منصه
لاستلام الشكاوى والابلاغات من المواطنين
اي شخص يرى ان هنالك ما يسيء الى المجتمع
والى تقاليد المجتمع تكون هنالك لجنه تدرس
واحوى
مساله الاساءه للمجتمع العراقي كيف هل لك
ان تعطينا مثالا عن اي شيء نتحدث عن اساءه
المجتمع العراقي
نعم نحن نتكلم عن محتويات
فيها وضوح كافي وفيها معالم واضحه ودرجه
كافيه من الوضوح على ان تعتبر مسيئه
للمجتمع العراقي كان يكون فيها كلام فاحش
كان يكون فيها تعري كان يكون فيها تعمد
افساد الاخرين وهكذا حينما يكون هنالك
اشتباه بهكذا موضوع يعرض على القضاء
العراقي قاضي التحقيق هو من يتخذ القرار
بشان قبول هذه الشكوى
ووصولها الى درجه كافيه من الوضوح
لاعتبارها انتهاك صريح لقانون العقوبات
العراقي طيب اتوجه حضره اللواء الى رسلي
صانع المحتوى طيب رسلي ما دام انه هذه
المنصه من قبل وزاره الداخليه تستهدف كل
من يسيء للاداب الذوق العام خدش الحياء او
ايحاءات وعبارات غير اخلاق ملابس غير
لائقه لماذا تهاجمونها
صباح الخير عليكم
في الحقيقه هي ليست مهاجمه للمنصه بنفسها
هي
طلب كما ورد في التقرير الان هو طلب
المزيد من التوضيح حول تعريف المحتوى
الهابط
لان هناك ما قد يؤخذ بنظر القاضي بمساحه
من من المطاطيه قد تستهدف ما هو ابعد من
قضيه المحتوى الهابط هناك من بدا الان
باطلاق اشاعات حول استهداف
كتاب يعني محتواهم سياسي نقد للواقع الوضع
العام في العراق الواقع السياسي وانه قد
تقالهم مساله المحتوى الهابط لانهم صنفوها
على ان محتوى هابط وانها قد تذهب الى ابعد
من هذا الى
مساله انتربول وقائمه انتربول طبعا هذه
فيها كلام طويل ويبدو انه مجرد كلام خالي
من المعلومه عن طبيعه عمل الانتربول لكننا
لا نريد ان تعطى المطاطيه فقط هناك موسيقى
[موسيقى]
تواصل معكم بشكل واضح نعم
لكي تتمكن انه من التاكد من كل هذه الامور
وسنذهب الى حضره اللواء مره اخرى حضره
اللواء الى اي حد هناك اتهامات اليوم بانه
قد يجير هذا القرار سياسيا اي يتم توجيه
اتهامات لمن توجهاته السياسيه تختلف مع
توجهات الحكومه الحاليه ما تعليقكم
نعم هو رغم انه هنالك مخاوف لدى البعض
ان تكون هذه بدايه لحمله تكميم افواه او
ما شابه ذلك
لكننا بدورنا يعني ننفي هذا الموضوع ونقول
انه هذا الشيء هو مبالغ فيه والسبب انه
اليوم الدستور العراقي هو من يتكفل بحمايه
الحريات الشخصيه والحريات السياسيه
والدستور العراقي له العلويه على كافه
القوانين لذلك موضوع الراي وموضوع
يعني
النقد او غيرها من هذه الامور يعني لا
تطال
بهذا الموضوع وانما نكتفي بالقضايا التي
تشكل احنا شفنا اسماء صحفيين يعني اليوم
صحفيين لا لهم علاقه بمحتوى هابط ولا
بتعري ولا بالفاظ خادشه للحياء ولا حتى
الرئيسه على المجتمع العراقي لماذا اذا
ما اعتقد هذا الكلام دقيق يعني انه صحفي
يطال عن خلفيه رايي الشخصي لا بالعكس
اليوم اغلب الفضائيات تهاجم الحكومه
وتهاجم السياسيين وهنالك هامش من الحريه
بهذا الاتجاه والجميع يعرف هذا الموضوع
لكن هي حينما يكون هنالك انتهاك صريح
وواضح للقانون سوى مو فقط المنصه تستهدف
قضايا الابتدالات والقضايا المنافيه
للاداب والاخلاق وانما كل قضيه فيها
انتهاك للقانون صريح وواضح
يعني التهديد الاشخاص
الشتم
التحريض على العنف اثاره عوامل الكراهيه
وغيرها من الامور اللي يمنعها القانون
العراقي وهكذا نتلقى يعني
بلغ العدد تجاوز المئه الف ابلاغ وهذا
مؤشر على انه هنالك تجاوب جماهيري وشعبي
اتجاه ما يعني المبادره التي اطلقتها
وزاره الداخليه طيب ارسلي كما سمعت حضره
اللواء يعني المنصه تستهدف فقط المحتوى
المسيء للاداب اول محرض على العنف غير ذلك
الدستور العراقي يكفى الحريه التعبير ما
رايكم بذلك
هناك المساله الان لا تخص وزاره الداخليه
واجراءاتها ولكن هناك من يشيع اسماء
الصحفيين والكتاب واصحاب الراي العراقيين
على انه هناك متابعه من قبل وزاره
الداخليه لهم داخل وخارج العراق برايي
يعني نحن نتمنى ان تتخذ وزاره الداخليه
اجراءات اتجاه من يطلق هذه الاشاعات لان
هذه الاشاعات تؤدي بالنتيجه او يراد لها
ان تضع هؤلاء الكتاب وهؤلاء اصحيين
بمواجهه اجهزه الدوله كما لو كانت
المواجهه فيما بينهم لكن هناك طرف اخر هو
الذي يشيع هذه القوائم هو الذي يحرض عليهم
وهذا نوع من التحريض بالمناسب هذا نوع من
التحرير على قضيه ليست لها علاقه بما
يقوله السيد اللواء التي تقص المحتوى
الهابط هناك صحفيون لهم ارائهم السياسيه
الماده 38 من الدستور التي تكفي حريه
التعبير ولذلك هذا التحرير بهذه الطريقه
واشاعه مساله ان الدوله العراقيه او
الحكومه العراقيه واجهزه الامنيه والقضاء
يطاردون بطريقه ما
صحفيين واصحاب رايي هذا سيضع الصحفي
بمواجهه هذه الاجهزه وهذه الاجهزه بمواجهه
الصحفي فيما يشيع الاخر ما يشير لذلك
هؤلاء ايضا يراد لهم عدم زج الطرفين في
مواجهه يكونونهم بمنع عنها وربما هي هذه
امنيات اكثر ما هي يعني امنيات من هذه
الاطراف اكثر مما هي واقعه لانه حسب الان
كلام السيد اللواء وحسب قوانين ولائحه
الانتربول اساسا لا يمكن اعتقال اي اي
كاتب او اي صحفي على حريه راي جرائم
الانتربول واضحه وفيها الكثير من التفاصيل
التي لا تتيح لهذه الشرطه اعتقال ايا كان
من هؤلاء
يجب اتخاذ اتخاذ اجراءات تجاه من يروج
لهذه الاشاعات
سياده اللواء اليوم نعم هو الحقيقه اليس
من الافضل لوزاره الداخليه تخصيص منصات
للابلاغ عن الفساد وشبهات الفساد في
المحلات وفي الاماكن وحتى في الدوائر
الحكوميه بدلا من ملاحقه حسابات شخصيه في
العراق
يعني هو مصطلح الفساد فيه طيف واسع من
الجرائم وهنالك جهات متخصصه بمكافحه
الفساد
كهيئه النزاهه على سبيل المثال
لذلك مصطلح الفساد مصطلح واسع يعني هل هو
فساد اداري فساد اخلاقي فساد مالي
تقصير بشنو يعني يعني هو اي انتهاك لاصل
القانون وزاره الداخليه هي جهه التنفيذيه
المعنيه بانفاذ القانون وبالتالي اي ماده
قانونيه يكون هنالك فيها توصيف
لمخالفه او جنايه او جنحه يكون هنالك
اجراءات من وزاره الداخليه وتعرض على
القضاء العراقي بالنسبه الملاحظه استاذ
وسيم انه فعلا اليوم احنا في بلد يعني
تنتشر فيه الاشاعات ارسلي عفوا تنتشر فيه
الاشاعات بسرعه كبيره جدا
ويعني في بعض الاحيان في اليوم الواحد
تكون عشرات بالمئات الاشاعات تخص مواضيع
شتى لدينا قسم متخصص في مكافحه الشائعات
في وزاره الداخليه
ويعني بسبب يعني تنامي وتوسع السوشيال
ميديا يعني هنالك يعني تنتشر الاشاعات
سواء بشكل قصدي او في بعض الاحيان واكثر
الاحيان بدون قصد
جزيلا لكما من اسطنبول لرسل الملك الكاتب
والصانع محتوى عراقي وايضا من بغداد
اللواء خالد يوحنا المتحدث باسم وزاره
الداخليه العراقيه